no marussia bonus a was born and raised
in tow cosa township in johannesburg
during the apartheid era she her family
and her community experienced
discrimination dehumanization and the
systematic violation of their human
rights this turned her into a lifelong
freedom fighter I committed myself to be
any an activist and to fight for the
human rights after that pain when I
received the news that what happened to
my mother and when I see what was
happening around the community I started
to say that I will fight against
apartheid I will fight against this
regime I will fight against any human
rights violation her mother was
subjected to sexual violence by soldiers
she shared this fate with many other
women they're still waiting for official
recognition of their suffering no
marussia fights tirelessly for their
rights her organization documents each
individual story but the country's
leaders are not listening we are saying
why the governess Oh Gavin dalida and
were directing our leaders today Grodd
grassroots level issues which we don't
want to be imposed by the leaders to say
what to do without a hearing from us no
marussia bana say is a natural born
leader even as a child she had a strong
sense of justice people come to her with
their stories they trust her and don't
have anyone else to turn to her
organization is called cumani that means
speak out and that's what she does his
body is trying to make sure that our
government is addressing the issues and
the upper Tate issues which has been
left unattended by the TLC and there
and government which I'm not looking at
the current issues which is happening at
the grass root level the society that no
marussia and her children live in is
supposed to be reconciled that was the
truth and reconciliation commission's
task following apartheid but they only
did half the job and no marussia wants
to correct that the healing process is
needed a little place is needed in order
to transform de de de de de de the
country and in also to prevented a
relocation the repetition we said that
long time is cruel many members now
faced with the repetition the other
currents of the human race religion in
our present democratic government
protesters opposing police brutality
such as the marikana massacre in 2012
where countless people were shot dead
show that the struggle is not over only
when the wounds of the past are healed
can a healthy society evolve and this is
what Nomar Russia is tirelessly fighting
for